la mortalité dans les camps soviétiques
est très élevée de l'ordre du tiers un
tiers des soldats allemands ne
rentreront pas de captivité mais je
pense aussi que les allemands projette
sur les soviétiques se les crimes qu eux
mêmes ont commis je vous rappelle que
sur les les
les deux millions les presque 3 millions
soldats soviétiques capturé avant avril
elle a plus de deux millions deux cent
mille qui vont mourir dans des
conditions abominables dans des camps à
ciel ouvert avec des scènes de
cannibalisme atroce
parce qu'on ne les nourrit pas ils ont
été condamnés à mort ont littéralement
par la direction de la sphère martin
donc je pense que les allemands savent
très bien ce que que la vengeance que le
soldat soviétique il va se venger parce
que d'une façon ils ont tous vu les
crimes terribles ont été commis en une
hausse symétrique
tous les combattants de l'est le savent
et l'ont vu et l'ont accepté et souvent
ayant participé maintenant que le soldat
soviétique rentrer en allemagne
ils savent que ça va être terrible on
avait eu un avant goût d'ailleurs en
novembre 44 cas numéro 9
mais effectivement ça sera
particulièrement terrible
le commandement de l'armée rouge
n'arrivera pas à tenir ses hommes malgré
un certain nombre d'ordres qui ont été
données ils n'arriveront pas les tenir
et je dirais que c'est un des facteurs
qui empêchait de jouques of de prendre
berlin plutôt à un moment donné l'armé a
été au bord de se dissoudre dans une
orgie une orgie de deux viols de
pillages de meurtre de de talent cole
c'est apocalyptique ce qui se passe à
l'est de l'allemagne c'est pas par
hasard si des millions d'allemands en
plein hiver avec des charrettes à
chevaux des landaus prennent la
direction de l'ouest et chaque fois que
le soldat allemand pourra éviter la
captivité à l'est face aux soviétiques
il le fera le résultat en effet c'est
que quand les armées quand les
américains passent le rhin donc à partir
du 28 mars 1945 il n'y a plus vraiment
de résistance il ya quelques noeuds
quelques nids par ci par là mais il ya
partout des drapeaux blancs on se rend
par centaines de milliers
inspecteur que l'armée rouge ne
connaîtra jamais
[Musique]